i'm getting rid of this corvette
situation and here we go game two
here we go game two and we have started
with the king's pawn again
so white opening and okay we don't see
the spanish this time we see the italian
game
this is how they battled several times
in the new and chess classic last month
but it's also how they battled
yesterday or in the prelims uh of this
event so
what will magnus come up with from the
white side he's had a decent amount of
success
with this opening against nakamura
everybody seems to play against nakamura
these days
he's very predictable in this opening
but k magnus coming up with the first
small surprise just pushing his corner
pawn there
just covering some squares that's a very
useful move in general it's rare to see
it this early
usually white maybe wants to develop
some pieces wants to control the center
but
nakamura when in doubt just play copycat
the corner pawn
it's actually a bit of a speciality of
magnus he has played it about six or
seven times
and usually in in the italian game which
is characterized by those bishops we see
on the left side by the the development
of those bishops normally it comes down
to maneuvering
lots of different move orders i always
get so confused when i'm trying to study
this opening
which pawn should go where and in what
order
now nakamura gains space on the other
side of the board just
controlling some squares also creating
an escape route for the black bishop to
retreat to
now magnus jumps forward in the center
camaro he plays tens of thousands of
games
per year online um and all of these
openings there's so many different
reward nuances they all kind of blend
into one eventually
he does repeat what he did last time the
black bishop stepping back and now
magnus says you go back i'm gonna go
forwards and magnus bringing his bishop
out this time so
nakamura well i was going to say
[Music]
well is carolina yes and carowanna's
game
oh nakamura is repeating exactly what he
did against the fabiano caruana
and you can see that magnus is so not
faced he is just uh
letting yep and again hikaru is
repeating
and totally the same white bringing his
knight forward temporarily white was one
point up but we did see that black
did retreat with his knight now
controlling a very nice central outpost
with the black knight and he's still
looking down
trying to remember things he just needs
to play the position afresh
completely reset look we're getting that
variation i showed on the board a few
moments ago
nakamura he found his courage he allowed
this sacrifice i'm going to defend and
will we see that backfire magnus look at
the clock situation magnus says gain
time he's gained one and a half minutes
for sure he has studied this
actually this morning and um that's very
brave by nakamura to allow it
so it's kind of quite an interesting
pause for magnus here so
do you think that he's uh calculating
out all the possibilities
or is he simply just intuitively finding
the right way to pressure okay so the
rook well
we did mention he loves his rook lifts
right now the black bishop has had to
step back as we mentioned
nakamura reacting slightly we're not
sure why
but now we see magnus he brings his rook
across i was expecting the knight
to jump in to attack that bishop but
this looks pretty strong as well
i totally agree with you i mean if you
look at black's extra piece
okay we're going to see it on the board
so uh
hikaru retreats tonight and
it's also ice cold he just retreats his
rook one square
it does look like black's trying to
defend but white has so many threats
play a move and uh you immediately see
that it loses in the most natural
well having said that uh hikaru does
find the top computer suggestion he has
moved
his rook to the middle of the board and
uh how is magnus gonna
fight this but he was just very relieved
and very happy that he made it through
right yeah and the same with napolita
yeah
both of these guys were so relieved to
be
in the knockout stages um it was so nice
to see that
the smiles and delights and we do have a
move
so uh magnus not attacking the
well he's delaying the attack on the
bishop instead he chooses to exchange
knights and now this
really deadly bishop retreat is coming
and
hikaru has problems in
on his hands on that square so nakamura
slightly grimacing he does put that
knight
he does retreat that night i mentioned
earlier that rhyme knights on f8 there
is no mate so we're going to find out
the truth
you want to really attack that light
square bishop so
one move that kind of springs to mind is
like pushing harry
another one is to jump into the center
with a knight so
she does okay what she does yeah so
magnus i was gonna say
you can't really do anything in that
position you ask some material down you
have to keep
well i was told that attacking when i
was young i was told that attacking is
like riding a bike you have to keep
pedaling otherwise you'll just fall off
and therefore magnus he does start to
create the threats i think
any of those moves would have been good
enough but um it's still not over you
still have to be
super accurate here and that knight now
is eyeing up that black bishop white has
four pieces
attacking the same bishop strong
attacking knight or he can play this
move he can defend his bishop
from the side with his rook white does
have okay he attacks the black rook
first okay that black rook most likely
will just sidestep
so black's defending only three times
white attacking four times that means
you can cash in
you can take on that square and at the
very end you win a pawn
just to prove a piece but that would be
slightly slow it would give black a
couple of moves to bring
more pieces to the defense so magnus
decides that's the moment
he takes the bishop finally that bishop
it was living on borrowed time
it was destined to fall eventually and
now magnus carson he
has taken again on that square white is
actually threatening
checkmate in a couple of moves so black
has to trade pieces to make sure his
king survives
that's king hiding in the center now
after some trades if we do a quick count
white has three pawns for a bishop so
bishop were three pawns
uh yeah roughly balanced material but
look how
bare that black king is no protection
around it at all
he he probably wishes that magnus was
low on the clock as well
so that he couldn't find the right
moment to bring that rook in but magnus
just giving some checks gaining a bit of
time on the clock asking the black king
where it's going
okay well he's actually made a move and
he's put his king on the edge of the
board okay we don't need to bring up
analysis board
because uh magnus is gonna share it
let's show it okay this white rook
is gonna do the final job if you could
imagine picking up this rook and
planting it on this square this would be
checkmate so that's why magnus he's
aiming towards that square
he's well he found a root in for the
rook he's going to try and do another
rook lift we mentioned this earlier he
knows
all about rook lifts and nakamura
setting a small trap he brought his rook
in
so that if magnus now puts his rook on
the wrong square if he brings it to this
one
trying to give checkmate then suddenly
nakamura would counter-attack he
would give a check the white king would
hide and suddenly
pin there's a pin along this diagonal
with the white rook would be lost
that's why magnus found a better square
for his rook uh he's lifted his rook to
this square
checkmate is coming now he put his rook
on the opposite color from the
opponent's bishop
let's go back to the players checkmate
is coming um
okay yeah i mean i think both both
players they have been the masters of
their own demise
in the last couple of games so yeah for
sure black is struggling in this match
it's just a struggle to get out of the
opening and nakamura he's just finally
trying to find one final trick but he
just resigns
about to get checkmated magnus carson
looking happy there with the head bob
wow it's a comeback from magnus carlsen
after losing the first game
he's coming back in the second one with
the white pieces winning